Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Ben, vas-y ! Vas-y, c’est à toi.
Tu ne veux pas y aller, c’est ça ?
Tu as peur ?
Tu ne veux pas te montrer ?
Mais ce n’était pas prévu, ça.
Bon, écoute, allez, donne.
Il ne veut pas venir.
Ce n’est pas facile pour lui.
Je vous laisse imaginer.
Une femme vient d'accoucher.
Le médecin annonce à cette jeune mère
que son fils a un bec de lièvre.
Elle l'imagine avec un vrai bec de lièvre.
La sage-femme apporte le bébé
et le dépose sur son ventre.
Elle voit effectivement un trou
au niveau de la lèvre supérieure.
Avec le regard et l’amour d’une mère,
elle voit aussi et surtout
les perspectives d’amélioration.
Elle entrevoit immédiatement les possibles
et n’a d’yeux que pour son sourire.
Les « bébés sourire »,
c’est comme ça qu’on les appelle,
ceux qui naissent avec une fente
labio-palatine - FLP comme on dit.
Le bébé se présente avec le palet ouvert,
la lèvre ouverte
et le nez qui part en vrille.
Une des maladies congénitales les plus
courantes : une naissance sur 700.
Ça veut dire que
sur 700 000 naissances en moyenne,
1000 bébés naissent
avec une fente labio-palatine.
C’est beaucoup - ou pas.
Ou ce n’est pas de chance.
Dans l’équivalent de cette salle...
c’est lui.
Est-ce qu’il y a quelqu’un d’autre
pour contredire les statistiques ?
Non ?
Eh bien, c’est vraiment lui alors.
(Rit)
C'est lui à trois mois.
Voilà comment
il s’est présenté à l’humanité.
Il y a mieux pour démarrer dans la vie.
Petit, à quel modèle s’identifier,
lui qui, sans cesse,
est défini par ce qu’il n’est pas
ou par ce qu’il n’a pas ?
Comment se reconstruire ensuite ?
Il voulait partager son parcours.
Je suis son ami,
je vais le faire à sa place.
Dans un premier temps,
il a fallu qu’il se répare pour survivre.
Son parcours médical est chargé.
Il bénéficie d'un traitement
pluridisciplinaire long.
Des rendez-vous avec des spécialistes -
orthophonie, orthodontie, ORL -
et des interventions
chirurgicales successives.
Son père exprime son amour différemment.
Il est plus inquiet, plus angoissé.
Mon ami subit une première opération à
un an pour refermer la lèvre et le palais.
Il ne pouvait pas être opéré plus tôt :
il faisait des otites aiguës à répétition,
ce qui empêchait toute intervention.
Son père est enfin rassuré.
Ensuite, il subit deux autres
opérations du nez, dont une à 16 ans.
Normalement, c’est une seule
opération à 18 ans,
mais comme c’est un peu compliqué
avec les filles,
il bénéficie d’une première
opération anticipée.
À son réveil, il pleure beaucoup.
C’est d’abord une reconnaissance
envers son chirurgien,
le même qui l’a opéré trois fois.
Mais c’est aussi une renaissance
envers lui-même.
De courte durée.
Cette période de réparation
le marque profondément.
Il se réfugie dans la solitude.
Je le trouve anxieux.
Alors pour l’encourager,
j’ai inventé pour lui un smiley.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Ses premiers contacts
avec la société sont compliqués.
Lui, bébé, Il sourit ouvertement.
Les regards sont gênés, consternés.
Sa mère leur dit : « Mais regardez-le,
il vous sourit. Rendez-le-lui ! »
Et la voisine qui dit :
« Oh ! Il ressemble à...
Enfin, il ressemble...
Il ressemble... Non.
(Rit.)
Il ne ressemble à rien, quoi. »
Dès ses premières rencontres, les regards
se focalisent sur son handicap.
À l’école, on se moque de lui
dans la cour.
Il y a même des dessins,
des caricatures à son effigie
placardées sur les murs du lycée.
Ces regards moqueurs, intrusifs,
fuyants, détournés,
seront déterminants dans sa vie.
Il faut trouver sa place dans le groupe.
Pour se rendre compte finalement
qu'il n'y en a pas.
Un véritable parcours d’acceptation de soi
à travers la haine et les moqueries
suscitées par sa différence.
Alors, avec une énergie folle -
et j’en suis admiratif -
il décide de prendre sa place,
de s’intégrer malgré son stigmate.
Il veut le crier :
« Reconnaissez-moi ! Regardez-moi ! »
La nature a voulu l’empêcher de respirer,
il le fera dans l’eau - niv. 5 en plongée.
La nature a voulu l'empêcher
de communiquer.
Il s’épanouit dans l’art de vendre,
et il est très bon.
Il a perdu la face à la naissance.
Vous savez ce que ça veut dire
« perdre la face » ?
C’est ne plus avoir ce masque
qui protège votre être intérieur.
À travers ce trou béant,
on voit tout de lui.
Même après la première opération, il a
l’impression d’être à nu devant l’autre.
Dans le théâtre, il arrive à se protéger
en incarnant des personnages, des rôles.
Son premier rôle à l'adolescence est
étonnamment le beau Roméo de Shakespeare.
Parlons de beauté, c’est le sujet du bac
de philo : « Qu’est-ce que la beauté ? »
Il sait tellement ce que ça n’est pas
qu’il réussit brillamment l’épreuve.
Il continue encore aujourd’hui
à faire du théâtre.
Le temps du masque.
Le temps du masque sur scène, dans la vie.
Le temps du masque pour se ressourcer.
Ce temps du masque est nécessaire.
C’est une trêve avec des rôles, des
personnages, qui le repose un peu.
Ici, au bout du monde, il rencontre sa
femme avec une bouche bien dessinée
qui s'ouvre sur un sourire parfait.
Il a deux enfants, beaux.
Il n'en revient toujours pas.
Voilà, je suis là à parler de lui.
C’est mon ami, un vrai, authentique.
Comme un ami, on se perd
de vue, on se retrouve.
Il a toujours été présent dans ma vie.
C’est comme un phare,
on s’éclaire mutuellement.
Et quand on s’éloigne,
le phare de l’amitié est toujours là.
Le temps passe et nous n'avons jamais
été aussi proches l'un de l'autre.
Je serais heureux de le voir sur scène.
La nature a voulu supprimer l’oralité.
Il l’a récupérée toute sa vie jusqu’à ce
jour ultime, ce moment, là, cet instant.
Être et s’exprimer devant vous
sur la scène du TEDx,
dans le temple de l’oralité.
Attendez, je vais le chercher.
Vas-y là. Maintenant, c’est à toi. Allez !
(Applaudissements)
Merci.